معنى ربما نحاول ان نفهم الروايه
الاسرائيليه عن ملابسات ما جرى وماذا
ستفعل اسرائيل بجثمان الشهيد الان
اسرائيل ربما الكيان الوحيد في هذا العالم
الذي لديه سجن للجثمين هناك ثلاثه عشره
جثامين لاسرى استشهدوا داخل السجون محتجزه
لدى السلطات الاسرائيليه وهو ما متوقع ان
تفعله على الاقل في الفتره المقبله بجثمان
الشهيد الشيخ خضر عدنان اسرائيل من
ناحيتها كانت دائما تتملص حتى خلال
اضرابها عن الطعام وخلال المحكمه الاخيره
هي لم تحاول ان تنقله الى مستشفى مثل ما
كان يطالب محاموه مستشفى حقيقي ابقته في
زنزانته وعندما تدهورت حالته نقلته الى
عياده السجن حيث استشهد فجر هذا اليوم من
ناحيتها هذه السياسه جاءت في ظل سياسه
اعلن عنها وزيره الامن القومي الاسرائيلي
تمر بن جبير والتي تستهدف الاسرى بشكل خاص
وكان صريحا عندما اعلن بان الاسى وكان
يتهم الاسرى كانهم يعيشون في فنادق خمس
نجوم علما ان وضعهم قاس جدا داخل السجون
الاسرائيليه
تذيقهم سلطات الاحتلال امرين لكنه زاد من
هذه المراره ومن هذه
الملاحقات السلطات الاسرائيليه لم تصدر
بيانا واضحا حول حقيقه ما جرى لكن ما
يتردد وما يتسرب انها عثرت عليه في
زنزانته وقد انهار تماما في حاله اغماء
نقل الى العياده في مستشفى الرمله في سجن
الرمله عفوا وهناك فارق الحياه وهي تدرك
جيدا بانها متهمه على الاقل من وجهه نظر
على الفلسطينيين بالاهمال الطبي وانها لم
تقدم له الخدمات اللازمه وان اضرابه عن
الطعام كان عادلا من وجهه نظرا
الفلسطينيين لانه كان يريد الحريه او ان
تكون له محاكمه على الاقل الشيخ عدنان كان
قد اعتقل عده مرات في السابق ومجموع
اعتقالاته 12 عاما كانت معظمها اعت اداريه
اي بمعنى انه كان يوضع رهن الاعتقال خلف
القضبان دون محاكمه ودون لائحه اتهام وهو
ما يشير الى ان السلطات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لا تملك حتى ادله لادانته فيها
هذه المره 87 يوما منذ اعتقاله بدا اضرابا
عن الطعام وهو يطالب بان يتم الافراج عنه
عندما بدا اضرابه يتفاقم طلب محاماه بان
يتم نقله وكانت هناك خطوره عليه طلب
محاموه بان يتم نقله الى مستشفى حقيقي
وليس الى عياده غير مؤهله في السجن وهو ما
تسبب
بمفارقته الحياه واستشهاده الفلسطينيه من
ناحيتهم ينظرون ببالغ الخطوره بهذا التطور
لان الاسير كان وديعه بمعنى حسب القانون
الدولي هو وديعه في ايدي السلطات الحاكمه
وهي لم تصم تلك الوديعه وتسببت ابي
استشهاده وباتوا يخشون اكثر على الاسرى
الباقون في السجين البقين في الس
الاسرائيليه
ويعتقدون بان سلطات الاحتلال تمارس سياسه
قمعيه وحشيه ضدهم قد تتسبب بسقوط المزيد
من الاسرى لذلك هذا الغضب في الشارع
الفلسطيني الذي قد يتحول الى مسيرات او
يعبر عن نفسه باشكال مختلفه هو مفهوم لدى
الكثيرين هناك ادانه بطبيعه الحال حتى
للمؤسسات الدوليه التي تعنى بالاسرى هناك
ادانه او هناك نوع من عدم الرضا في الشارع
الفلسطيني تجاه كافه النخب الفلسطينيه
بدءا بالسلطه والفصائل الكافه بانها كانت
قد تقاعست في هذه القضيه خلال الايام
الماضيه كان يجب ان يكون هناك حراك يدعو
لانقاذ حياته والان بعد ان استشهد قد يصبح
الوضع اسوء واكثر خطوره بالنسبه للحركه
الاسيره الحركه الاسيره في السجون
الاسرائيليه هي الاخرى بدات تعبر عن غضبها
في كافه
السجون والمعلومات الوارده تشير الى ربما
يفكرون في خطوات ايضا احتجاجيه على نطاق
واسع لحمايه انفسهم وايضا احتجاجا على
عمليه ما يصفها الفلسطينيون القتل المتعمد
للشيخ
خضر عدنان في اسرائيل كما قلت لم يصدر
بيان حتى الان المعلومات الوارده من مصادر
الفلسطينيه ومنقوله عن جهات الرسميه هو
انه تم نقل جثمان الشهيد عدنان الى معهد
الطب العدلي في تل ابيب لتشريحه لكن ليس
هناك مؤشرات ما اذا سيتم تسليم الجثمان ام
لا ونشير مجددا الى ان هناك اجثمين ثلاثه
عشر شهيدا اسيرا محتجزه لدى السلطات هل
هذا يعني وليد بانه ما تطالب به السلطه
الفلسطينيه من التحقيق
ويعتمد بطبيعه الحال على التشريح وايضا
الملابسات هل سبق وان تعاونت اسرائيل في
اي قضيه سابقه مما يسمح بالفعل بكشف حقيقه
ما جرى للشهيد خضر عدنا
سبق وكان يشارك في بعض الاحيان مشرحون اما
دوليون او اطباء فلسطينيون متخصصون لكن لم
يفد كثيرا ذلك في القضايا التي كانت ترفع
لكنها خطوات عاده ما تاخذ مجرها هذه المره
لم تطلب السلطه السلطات الاسرائيليه تتصرف
بمفردها بهذا الخصوص السلطه الفلسطينيه
توجهت باعلنت انها ستتوجه بشكوى رسميه الى
الجنائيه الدوليه وايضا الى مطالبه باجراء
تحقيق للوقوف على حقيقه ملابسات وفاه
الشيخ عدنان داخل السجن الاسرائيلي الكل
باتا يترك بان الشيخ عدنان كان ضحيه اهمال
طبي من قبل السلطات السجون الاسرائيليه
وانه لم يتلقى العلاج اللازم وهو كان في
حاله اضراب متواصل عن الطعام ومنهج ادى
الى وفاته لكن السبب الرئيسي بنظر
الفلسطينيين هو المال الذي قابلته قضيته
من قبل السلطات الاسرائيليه عاده جرى في
ان يشارك مشرحون فلسطينيون او دوليون في
هذه القضايا لكن في نهايه المطاف من يتحكم
بالامر تبقى اسرائيل لانها هي التي تحتجز
الجثثيمين هي التي تعرف كافه التفاصيل
بالمناسبه هي لديها تصاوير وفيديوهات
كامله وتستطيع ان تعرف وتعرف الحقيقه
ومساله التحقيق هي التي يطالب فيها
الفلسطينيون هي ان تكون دوليه بالاساس
السؤال هل سيتحرك المجتمع الدولي ممثلا
سواء بالجنائيه الدوليه او منظمات حقوق
الانسان هذا سؤال هذا الموضوع جربه
الفلسطينيون كثيرا ودون جدوى الان الشارع
هو الذي قد يفرض المعادله خلال المرحله
المقبله